we have a Hollywood hero to tell you
about after Danny Trejo is being hailed
as a real-life hero the machete actor
was at a Los Angeles intersection
yesterday when an SUV collided with a
car Trejo and others ran over to find a
young boy trapped in the overturned SUV
he says he crawled in and with the help
of a female bystander unbuckled the
child's seat belt and pulled the boy out
I'm holding him like this and I started
talking about wait a minute we gotta use
our super powers and so he goes super
powers I just feel great that the Lord
put me right there in that spot to do
what I did
that's all anybody love it the boy's
grandmother was freed from the vehicle
by firefighters there were no serious
injury injuries we love superpowers and
love that he often plays a bad guy and
the roles that we see him in and here he
was a superhero that's a real superhero
right it's a real superhero they're
still investigating what exactly caused
the accident but I hope for him that
more Hollywood roles come exactly he
said he feels like it's good luck to
help you